These images have shocked the world: Venezuelan
soldiers preventing much needed aid from coming
into the country from neighboring Columbia.
But while the aid is kept OUT, a steady stream
of Venezuelans pour into the Columbian city
of Cucuta over the nearby Simon Bolivar Bridge.
Leaving behind hyperinflation and empty supermarket
shelves, these people exit via an official
border crossing.
Many others have not been able to obtain a
passport, and are forced to leave the country
via smuggling routes cutting through the dry
riverbed.
Known as "trochas," they are controlled by
criminal gangs, who extract a heavy transit
fee from the migrants.
It's a price they are willing to pay in the
hope of finding of work and a better life
in Colombia.
"I'm going to Medellin because I have family
there and we will work, because there is nothing
in Venezuela.
The more you wait, the worse the situation
in Venezuela will get."
Since neighboring countries demand that Venezuelans
show a passport, more and more people are
using the trochas to leave.
With no money for any transport, they often
have to walk for hundreds of miles.
It's a business opportunity for shoemaker
Domingo Montilla, who also fled across the
border.
"The shoes from the people that cross often
are damaged, they are falling apart.
So I sew them, for anybody who needs it."
Even regular commuters have taken to the trochas,
which snake through the riverbed only meters
from the bridge.
Carlos Carretero carries goods across the
border to sell in Venezuela on the black market.
Customs officers have clamped down on the
cross border trade, forcing Carlos off road
to continue his work.
"If migration doesn't let us work, we don’t
have any other choice but to use the trochas."
Carlos earns about 4 euros a day shuttling
goods across the border - barely enough to
get by.
While for many the trochas are an escape route,
for him they are a lifeline.